it's making history it's gonna break
record books saya black I thought the
superheroes like seeing myself as a
superhero it's like seeing me up there
it was kind of emotional at point I
actually cried I'm a field royal I'm
gonna feel dominant because now I didn't
see people like myself starring in a
movie
we love Marvel movies in general but
it's so great to know that my son can
look at the screen and see a hero that
looks like him it's pretty cool what an
impact reactions are pouring in from all
across the country to Black Panther the
latest comic book blockbuster from
Marvel Studios Black Panthers expected
to have a record-breaking opening
weekend at the box office Disney
estimates it made 25 million dollars on
Thursday alone and could earn as much as
198 million by Monday shattering the
February record it's the first superhero
film to feature a mostly black cast and
crew CBS this morning co-host Gayle King
sat down this week with Black Panthers
director Ryan Cooper what is the message
you want to send to young black kids who
are seeing this I mean I think um I mean
number one is to give them a good time
at the movies yes I think a lot yeah a
lot of talk that's overlooked you know I
think the value of them of being able to
go to the movies with your friends you
know watch something for two and a half
hours and come out of there feeling you
know exhilarating or the next day at
school pretending to be the characters
you know drawing drawing the characters
you know dressing up as him for
Halloween so that's that a lot of that
is overlooked and for me it was about my
own realization is that you know it's
okay to be proud to be African you know
you should be proud to be African you
know Airi why should be proud of their
own heritage no but especially us at the
end of the day though you said it best
you said I just wanted to make a good
movie
that's all and I mean in in that's so
difficult to do that that if we able to
accomplish that and that's enough I
think you can see all of Gail's
interview with Ryan Coogler tomorrow on
the CBS weekend news